put your arm put your math teacher hat
on for a second
okay maybe you're like i don't have a
message we'll get one and then put it on
now if i gave you this function and i
drew this graph
what kind of volume could we make with
it
you can make a couple different kinds
couldn't you probably tune a 3d you
would say well you can either choose
this axis
to rotate around and that would give you
sort of a nice
well it's something like a ball but it's
got sharp points at the ends
i suppose you could do it the other way
right and it would look like one of
those
upside down chiffon cake type things
okay
and you'd get you get these annular type
disks right
but that's all that's all very
pedestrian for me i wanted to move a
little further
right rotating just around the axis
that's so
that's so 2013 okay we can move past
that
let's rotate around something else tell
me
what's that point there what's that
what's that value
have a look at it
stationary point x equals two when i put
x equals two into there
it looks like i get four right okay well
if that's four
let's pick a point or rather let's pick
a line like
y equals six there's a line it's
straight relax it's not that hard
what if we rotate it around this okay
now what shape would you get
well don't forget right this is the area
under the curve
right this area under here
okay so that's what's going to rotate
around it's going to go all the way up
to the top
right if that's six you're gonna get
eight ten twelve so you'll have
something like this
up the top right i'm looking at it
straight on
okay now because i'm rotating
this area down here right what's going
to be in the middle
space right there'll be nothing there
it'll be hollow okay
but these two parts are going to connect
aren't they
hmm can you see it it looks like a yoyo
to me
well you're thinking of the inside which
is actually hollow
right so i actually want the outside of
the yoyo
is that okay a weird kind of shape but
that's what happens when you rotate
around somewhere awkward
now just pause for a minute and think
about how you would approach this
with this technique what would you do
i'm guessing you would want to think
about
the whole cylinder right the whole
cylinder
and then you would subtract the middle
part because we just said that was
hollow didn't we right
and so you would have to fashion some
way to work out what that middle part
is right that's tricky
that's that's that's quite difficult to
approach it that way
but we have a new tool in our toolbar
now right think about this
what would you get if this was your
shape
let's draw it let's pick a point pick
one up in the middle because that'll
give us something
nice and easy to visualize okay so if i
sliced it
perpendicular to the axis of rotation
right it's no big deal that the axe has
been moved off the um
the x-axis right i can still go
perpendicular i'll get a shape like this
for instance
yeah that's hard it's all clouded in the
middle there i'm going to draw off on
the side
just so i can really see what's going on
okay so let me
move this guy over for a second
okay i want to know what this annular
disc looks like this annulus slice
okay there you go now i can see a little
bit clearer now what i do before
all i need to know is an inner radius
and outer radius and then you can work
out the volume no problem
okay so what are the inner and outer
radii
here you know here's my um it might be
easier if i go down actually
here is my little r right and
here is my big r okay
hmm which is easy to work out
what's little r
now i think little r kind of depends
on big r here's what i mean think about
different kinds of slices we could take
and the different values that big r will
take okay think about it
this is our whole shape if i move this
slice over to the edge for instance what
would big r be
it'd be well it'd be six wouldn't it now
if i come somewhere into the middle like
where i've drawn what's big r
it's still six that's interesting so
your outer radius is constant that's
nice
okay now to work out what little r is
see that thing's changing isn't it
but we don't have little r as a function
look it's up off the axis
right but what i do have a function for
is this guy
i know what that is right because that's
been defined as
4x minus x squared right just for now
i'm just going to call it y rather than
write that because that's a bit awkward
okay now if this here which is not the
inner radius
right if that's y then what should this
be
it'll be the difference six minus y
right i might leave that in the lab
there actually six minus one
okay there you go i can deal with this i
can deal with this
right the volume i'm going to get from
here
right the volume is the integral from
now how far am i going from naught to
four
now what is the and the volume of the
annulus right
pi big one minus little one
with respect to x okay now what am i
going to get here let's see
we already established the big r is just
6. so that's 36
okay what's little r it's 6 minus y
6 minus y all squared 6 minus my l
squared that sounds like 36
minus 12 y
plus y squared is that okay that's my
little
r squared with respect to x
can you see now why i'm still keeping it
in terms of y's i could put it in terms
of x's
but when i do this it's just going to
sort of explode i want to do as much
simplifying as i can before i stick x in
36 is cancel don't they and i might as
well stick the pi out the front while
i'm at it
those go bang bang double negative
negative positive
now keeping in mind that we know exactly
what y is
it is well defined right and it's not
something gross i can put that in
it'll expand out and then it's just a
polynomial i can integrate that right
think about this remember how five
minutes ago we said how do we approach
this volume
using this and it's it's weird and it's
awkward and you have to come up with
tricks in order to work out what this
volume is in the middle right
but if you consider it just buy slices
what do slices look like i don't care
where the slices are
i know exactly what its volume will be
right
and so that's why it gets to this step
and you're like this is just integration
like it was before
okay so let's just finish it off shall
we
what am i going to get pi not to 4 okay
that's 4x minus x squared
that's 4x minus x squared
with respect to x it's all in x's now
you can crunch the numbers can't you
that's all that's left
number crunching right so i think when
you simplify out you expand here
and collect like terms you'll end up
with that and this is a trivial problem
for us
right you can just integrate that
evaluate
you know it's even nice and neat because
um all of these have x terms in them
so when you evaluate 0 that just
disappears so all you're interested in
really is the upper bound very simple
problem
okay so this idea which looked very
unimpressive before
right just a subtle shift thinking about
rather than
two big volumes and you subtract them
from the other versus
thinking about the slices individually
and then adding up a whole bunch of them
sometimes no difference why bother a lot
of times
incredibly powerful and time-saving